je me souviens parfaitement c'était en
octobre 2010
et nous étions sur ces mêmes bancs le 12
octobre une énorme manifestation une
énorme mobilisation 3 millions de
personnes
j'étais ici
je soutenais cette réforme
et je me souviens les mêmes arguments
souvent caricaturaux le même ton un
prétatoire la réforme est votée vous
arrivez ensuite au pouvoir l'avez-vous
aboli non vous ne l'avez pas aboli
vous l'avez
vous l'avez durci avec les 43 à nuités
de la réforme Touraine c'est ça la
vérité c'est ça le double langage ça
signifie aujourd'hui pour des Français
qui arrivent à 22 ans sur le marché du
travail un départ à taux plein un départ
à 65 ans voilà votre double langage oui
cette réforme nous l'avons déjà voté ici
nous l'assumons nous assumons le critère
d'âge nous l'assumons parce que c'est un
levier qui nous permettra de sauver le
régime des retraites c'est un levier
efficace c'est aussi parce que c'est un
filet de sécurité vous enlevez cette
borne d'âge et alors vous aurez une
machine à des côtes parce que vous savez
parfaitement que c'est ce qui crée des
retraités pauvres vous savez aussi que
la décode est plus modeste c'est le
double par rapport au décote des cadres
alors oui nous l'assumons nous
l'assumons parce que cette borne d'âge
permettra non seulement de sauver la
réforme et le régime par répartition et
même si la réforme est provisoirement un
populaire nous en avons connu d'autres
mais quand on est et quand on fait de la
politique on assume ce qui est bon pour
le pays et cette réforme à terme elle ne
sera pas abrogée pas plus que vous
n'aviez abrogé la précédente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]